[Music]
we can scrap let's go
Tiffany take it away this week we've got
leader beaver Oh
guard crag iron gangster toddler the
take you away Tiffany I like extra
toddlers infant toddler spot kids suffer
first are eucalyptus there was a beaver
that Maxim dentally became the leader of
a hundred and fifty cows whoa thank you
show you guys this a video that was
posted I would like to see this and so
by the way the six leaves in Canada so
they're just saying like this is the
most Canadian thing ever
why was so Canadian about it they're
just giving maple syrup to be because of
the fact that it's the beaver leading a
tire no beavers were Canadian I thought
it was like Moo C's I dunno you there
until I read those are different
claiming animals like that it's more up
about Canada goose Canada goose friend
oh I just keep thinking moose all right
nice I didn't know they got a hot cow in
a Canada yeah oh look at that guy he's
leading the pack but he's like sugar he
well-directed you she's like why are you
following me there ain't no body of
water they're using a dry ass land well
they just thought alike honey drop him
and keep it on three like three feet or
three but defense you nasty weather just
here are they just serious they're
falling in where whoa look at the whole
[ __ ] her holy [ __ ] boom how do you
move and I need to fallen into these
like my
that beavers a rapper with the whole
entourage they smell him though and you
know he's not their kind like they know
they're following him
then I what the hell is this creature
and CBB beef that's [ __ ] cute
oh man maybe there's like a scientific
explanation of what's going on uh why
was it by accident so they're saying
that uh this beaver was just looking for
a new home like a new area to create I
thought they left by creeps and stuff
maybe there's like a body of water
that's close but you start to travel
over to relation there's no branch well
I'm kind of I'm kind of disappointed why
I was picturing the beaver to be like a
real like life leader like what the ha
and a green is why do one of them like
his riding one of yeah like he's just
like come on and then he's guiding them
I laugh at my idea
did you know like I get it this is like
an accidental leader yeah like he's just
watching curious like huh are you
telling me it's not like follow me I'm
the leader beaver and then they just
follow him me to be like you've got Mel
Gibson go in Braveheart like giving his
[ __ ] like war speech ah
and then like all the cows are like
movie you know I was picturing that like
a big [ __ ] epic like yeah is that
what happened in July no our animals
don't speak yeah
dodge it fine because not you could be
cute or anything in your world no but
yeah it was like an accidental leader it
was like it was like a it was kind of
like I'm a beaver and it was like oh
what is this you're not a cow and then
it almost seems like the beaver cubes
like don't follow me
yeah tell me and then the guy who just
keep bottling the whole time and who are
you anyways more for good
when you do how already dumb are they
yeah
really I did it they're very smart
brainless pigeons they just eat grass
there's some delicious and I got close
to one a powerup is that close to yeah
couple of cows I forgot why would I
think I was in close as in proxemics or
close as in like we're friends like you
understood each other I got I got kind
of scared because it was like five of
them and then like they're just eating
grass and then I was like I'm a math
bucket I don't know can you show me how
to eat grass did you know he's delivery
girl hello attitude should do I'll get
this right yes I am golly that's like
the [ __ ] that's the voice that goes
with that baby [ __ ] which other yeah I
Fri next story there was this truck that
had a car jammed into his back tire and
was just dragging it in the freeway I
didn't know didn't even know something
was he all [ __ ] mess ya know so the
driver is after the fact they reported
that the driver didn't seem to be under
the influence of anything and they let
him go
we better move from the scene how big is
this truck unless the other car is so
small I'm going to show you yeah is it
dragging like a Mini Cooper smart car or
the Fiats oh okay maximum Oh what those
are huge
that's our maximum vigor than Altimas
yeah they're a full-size of that it's
[ __ ] big it's heavy a [ __ ] - yeah and
by the way this happened here in
California oh [ __ ] after 15 in the 138
this is a very serious was it well I
don't know nice drivin all right here we
go
holy [ __ ] all it's a oh my goodness
holiday in there yeah really like I'm
gonna dress passage over all the window
down you go holy holy [ __ ] he bats
popping Oh someone stop the truck
and so this guy pulls over he's like
[ __ ] job you're dragging the caller
got it
what is that
oh I know exactly about it oh it makes
sense it's one of those double trailers
letting me know it do all its like that
super wash you didn't even get out you
just pulled over back nothing so much
guy your humors can have why do you run
into it so wow it was crazy
so what happened what happened so when
he was driving there was a slower truck
ahead of this truck and so he was trying
to go around him and so when he went
into the left lane that's when he
collided with the with the Nissan but he
didn't realize I keep him here any like
horns and he doesn't feel it
yeah and that there were no mechanical
problems of the truck either for it to
cause that I can see how that happens to
that trailer is like at least like 10
car lengths back so even when they're
driving in a regular card you don't
really know what's going on or way back
there we have to be [ __ ] to work you
didn't look at what your side mirror one
you could have seen that [ __ ] that's
what that's exactly that me and my my
car the guy just came into my lane
didn't [ __ ] see me and he just no
actually this guy did see me so he said
he signaled it's to Val's gonna move out
the way but because I think certain
shredders like they're so used to being
like all on the big guy in the real get
the [ __ ] out my way yeah they just go in
if there's no space to move you're gonna
kill somebody you [ __ ] yeah that's why
you got to look for that sign it goes
how am i driving poor poor tell on you
PHP reported that this car was dragged
for only seven tenths of a mile so not
even how they know that they measured
the tire probably
baba contemplates an impact all the
[ __ ] get Morrissey [ __ ] yeah that's
so funny the guy is so casual in the car
he goes he won't stop yeah it was so
casual out of it like what you think no
honkies email the entire windshield and
everything was like obliterated
damn Wilson cold or that person who to
cut them up and just stayed in the front
and slow them down yeah I think I'd be
like the movies where I climb out of the
window and then climb onto the truck you
saw Kim even knows you and I'm happy a
lot of guidance of Kendall they were
taught that scene of the movies flips oh
yeah we go with this grip string is
unreal do meetings that someone point
out a bit [ __ ] I'm tired you know all
day - like three seconds one two three
in real life it should be looking like
[ __ ] a beginner doing bouldering
classes you're on a third rock in your
life project tired
he's like the [ __ ] slob I don't know
allow yourself a swift off you're gonna
push yourself off I'm totally departing
let's go try bro I got tired
all right so [ __ ] tell old [ __ ]
I mean harder hit the floor and they're
spinning what is very difficult right
back up dust myself up crackheads of
that note to self
remind me to try crack crack oh babe
hands up oh my god my last story there's
a gangster as toddler the five-year-old
who rat we've actually talked about this
kid before and I'm going to save you
guys recognized or not but I'm going to
show you this video clip the hot
knowledge it but he's threatening this
truck that is laughing business if you
guys remember I remember in
here make out anything holding a knife
oh [ __ ] she's trying to pop the tire is
where you open the door you knock about
Oh fun look at the way you want the way
gangster right before you back the way
he says if you don't move on my hit you
if you Chinese bully one is the one that
was on the on the right after that hang
if I saw my kid do that probably slap
upside his head super hard would be the
one on the hoverboard on his knee they
eating a popsicle Oh Becky kid okay now
here well when do we talk about this kid
so we talked about so first of all what
he was doing is he was defending his
grandma's ball so it's like a street
she's like a street vendor and so this
truck had blocked her stalls and that's
when this kid goes up to the truck and
saying things like you can't park here
you park here I'll beat you up it's a
nice yeah we're just good enough or no
but we did talk about this kid before
this is the video that we saw that's was
four years old
Oh ready you for taking the same song
with the metal pipe how cute he got
better
anything damn that kid is aggressive he
hit anger issues racking up too
[Music]
is that the police yeah honestly my judo
caught him with a couch there yeah let
me the cigarette dude [ __ ] stress or
maybe like a chill though it was like
you're not trying to be yeah so we can
do Dan I suppose the young you're
protecting his grandma where do you
learn that from oh no I said a lot of
people like online have been commenting
like man this is actually really sad
like you know this kid thinks that you
can resolve all his problems with
violence like that just shows what kind
of parents he has in the kind of
environment he's living it was like it
really another way to look at it is how
much love he has was grandma yeah how
many grandkids would defend a
grandparent innately like that like they
just start I wish my Marlon I hope so I
guess it was a question what if their
kids are innately better blessed to have
the best forever
wait so how old is he now
five see you next week 52 you guys see
violence I just see passionate I feel of
[Laughter]
terrible good I just see a lot of
passion in that kid is my grandma
I love him she has to see it everybody
stay away from her spawn any more
impactful yeah but instead I see a kid
with the knife kind of stabbed a tire
with the cigarette I'm like missing a
cigarette I don't even though hang my
cigarette that even though there wasn't
one yeah same okay I got to go to work
Republican [ __ ] you like that
actually as a kid absolutely very very
nice no I wasn't no that's pretty
terrible but still that was always you
but I didn't have knives in [ __ ] like
that that's all you're missing the
knives and the cigarette no the only
thing I did was I in kindergarten I had
a kid in the face with a pot holy [ __ ]
we're playing house also the cook I
didn't do it I take away my pot another
I don't cook him in the kitchen bro but
I do try to pot I went right in his head
really that was actually my first day of
kindergarten I didn't even know what
violence was in kindergarten I had no
idea it was hey did you punch people the
tickets no I didn't even know I didn't
know what what I wasn't tall when I was
in first grade I got keeping the mouth
and that's my first taste of violence I
was scared oh that was before he was
like this because I blood well besides
that yeah I thought a violence was I
thought like it was normal to get your
ass beat by a parent but not by other
people but not by other people
I thought only Presbyterians and then I
found out in the real world anyone can
kick your ass then you read dicted no my
mom told him didn't to fight that's such
a weird Asian parenting thing like they
tell you to get in fights and defend
yourself but you get in trouble in the
btris after like she was always so
gaining you for you to defend yourself
because my brother when he first came
here when he was five he couldn't speak
English and he had to go right in
kindergarten so people used to make fun
of him all the time so because of that
my dad said yo don't be a punk and
defend yourself but then at the same
time you would defend yourself you get
in trouble for fighting yeah and then
you can't be at home and in school look
like what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
then
you know something stop missing out on
all of the JK news uploads don't forget
to subscribe so you know when the
Biggers are coming up and for the last
video click over here
[Music]